vous avez le foin ce sont des métastases
depuis les deux dernières années le
docteur Martin champagne observe de plus
en plus de patients avec des cancers
avancés un des impacts de la pandémie on
n'arrive pas à combler les retards par
exemple en endoscopie pour des
coloscopies le défi est d'assurer
l'accessibilité aux soins parce qu'en
plus des retards liés à la pandémie un
plus grand nombre de personnes vivent
avec le Cancer et je ne suis pas certain
qu'on soit prêt pour faire face à cette
demande accrue là qu'on peut anticiper
c'est toujours des délais pour avoir
accès aux examens radiologiques donc
faut trouver des portes d'entrée rapide
dans le système pour que vous puissiez
entrer dans le système et le prix donc
en charge rapidement la Société
canadienne du cancer estime qu'en 2022
un million et demi de Canadiens ont ou
ont eu la maladie en 2012
193.000 personnes avaient reçu un
diagnostic de cancer en 2022 ce nombre
était de
33 900 personnes toujours plus de code
diagnostiqués parce que la population
vieillit le cancer est au premier chef
maladie chronique qui est associée avec
le vieillissement de la population et la
population continue de croire qu'il faut
surtout dans les réflexions qu'on a
notamment avec le plan du B la réforme
de la santé au Québec réfléchir à ça
comment est-ce qu'on va adresser cette
augmentation de cancer qui s'en vient à
l'avenir une des clés mettre l'accent
sur le dépistage on investit
probablement pas suffisamment dans la
prévention l'enseignement donc
préventif le dépistage précoce il existe
des possibilités de dépister pour le
cancer du col pour le cancer du poumon
pour le cancer de la prostate mais
présentement il y a pas de balise clair
de programme instaurer qui cible des
populations à risque des programmes de
dépistage qui devraient être accessibles
et automatique pour une certaine partie
de la population ici Marie-Isabelle
Rochon Radio-Canada Montréal